que suponen estos cambios en el gobierno
de boris se puede decir que hay un giro
al centro
ahora vamos a estar desgracias por
limitaciones efectivamente en lo más
relevante de estos cambios en el
gabinete en un giro al centro y mirando
al centro-izquierda
cobijándose en la experiencia política
de partidos de una de las almas de la
coalición como el socialismo democrático
con entregando la jefatura de gabinete a
la ministra tohá que es de un partido
del partido por la democracia de un
partido de la tradición de la
centroizquierda chilena entregando la
agenda legislativa las expresa analía
oriente que es fue asesora de la misma
presidenta michelle bachelet recibiría
gabriel boric se mueve hacia el centro
con la intención y con la necesidad de
generar diálogos no sólo dentro de su
propio sector no sólo para con la
democracia cristiana que no hace parte
del gobierno sino incluso mirando a
conversar con la derecha con la posición
de cada acampada gestión de gobierno
como así también
a lo que va a ser el próximo paso de
razón del plebiscito de la razón de lo
que se viene en la próxima convención el
proceso constituyente 2.0 digámoslo así
que debe armar de ahora en adelante
precisamente sobre ese tema al que usted
abordaba cómo puede facilitar entonces
este nuevo gabinete precisamente esas
negociaciones que pasan por el congreso
de ese proceso constituyente
porque efectivamente no solo son rostros
que la dialoga mejor con la
centroderecha y con la derecha sino que
también tienen una visión más vinculada
con generar puede es es decir son
sectores moderados no hacía algunos
sectores que son originales de la
coalición de gobierno de gabri podio
como el partido comunista que por
ejemplo en esta pasada pierde un
ministerio y en ese sentido el gobierno
va dejando pocos a ese timbre original
de la primera vuelta va dejando esa
vinculación con aquellos sectores que
dominaron en esta primera experiencia en
el primer paso de tve de esta convención
constitucional y se va a acercar
justamente a sectores más reconocidos
como dialogante y que hoy día el
presidente necesita no sólo por los
partidos sino que como decíamos
inicialmente porque son figuras que han
hecho parte de gobiernos anteriores y
que de esa manera suponen mayor
capacidad mayor experiencia política
también para de acuerdo el presidente
necesito urgentemente en la reforma
tributaria de la acción gubernamental
pero también el razón del próximo
proceso constituyente que entre esta
semana y la que viene se debe comenzar a
conversar negociar y articular en
términos de cómo va a ser este
reglamentado
para el rockstar